she's a one name one woman Legend the
ultimate triple threat of Our Generation
and arguably one of the most talented
vocal artists of all time obviously
we're talking about the queen bee
Beyonce Beyonce is known for her
mind-blowing performance chops and her
2018 Coachella performance was no
exception
[Music]
but surprise surprise most of the buzz
around the Beehive was around her body
and what she did to transform it for a
weekend of crop tops and Fringe skirts
So today we're going to be unpacking the
controversial Coachella diet and
flipping the script to attempt to eat
like Queen Bee for a day hey everyone
I'm Abby sharp welcome to Abby's kitchen
please
in today's video I'll be taking meal
inspiration from Megastar actress and
mother of three Mrs Beyonce Carter a
quick disclaimer that we will be talking
about restrictive diets so please feel
free to skip this video if it's not
supportive to your journey also this
diet was compiled from primary and
secondary sources so I really cannot
speak to the accuracy of Beyonce's
actual everyday diet it's also just what
I ate on a random day here it is not
meant to be copied or recommended as how
you should eat always speak to a
dietitian about your unique needs and
don't forget to hit that subscribe
button and follow me on Tick Tock and
Instagram at Abby's kitchen all right
first things first we need to unpack the
diet that caused the Beehive some
serious abuzzin let's talk Coachella
diet 101 so Coachella was considered a
Bay's official homecoming performance
after the birth of her twins roomie and
Sir
pretending that my son is flat in body
suits
[Music]
time for the side oh baby to prepare for
her debut she allegedly followed a
strict 44-day diet eliminating all bread
carbs sugar dairy meat fish and alcohol
in order for me to meet my goal I'm
limiting myself to no bread no carbs no
sugar no Dairy no meat no fish no
alcohol that's a lot of good things to
have to cut out
now if that is accurate it leaves us
only with things like beans nuts avocado
and low carb vegetables not surprisingly
Beyonce described the experience simply
and succinctly
I'm hungry I mean I'm really not
surprised so basically what this sounds
like is like a vegan keto diet or what I
like to call the veto diet because it
vetoes most foods and food groups
basically we take two diets with
completely opposite restrictions smash
them together and live off thoughts and
prayers
no but really I am all for a plant-based
diet but when you cut out all the carbs
like where the [__] did this girl get
the energy to do this
I mean we already knew this but Beyonce
clearly has some kind of superpower that
we may never understand
and she clearly rocked the concert so
sure maybe this diet worked for her in
the short term but for most of us mere
mortals this would not feel good we're
looking at low energy levels from lack
of carbs poor satiety from the
relatively lower amounts of protein and
low energy availability from the calorie
deficit and the strenuous exercise
regimen like this is generally a recipe
for Burnout and injury so Abby trust me
don't bother with this noted
like the very beginning Destiny's Child
was the first concert I ever went to as
a kid and it was amazing bootylicious
tour
get at me like to this day the best
concert I've ever seen Nelly was
performing Nelly if that's not 2 000 for
you I don't know it is so I fully
support all the praise and admiration
that woman has gotten over her career
and I also empathize with the pressure
she must have felt leading up to this
very important show but yeah
this diet is not it at least not with
all of those restrictions in place that
said the Coachella date was allegedly
based off of this 22-day vegan meal plan
that was developed by her friend and
trainer Marco Bourget and if we ignore
like the laundry list of no no no foods
for Coachella
I mean there's definitely some pretty
solid ideas here for building out some
great plant-based meals and it's totally
possible that this is actually what she
ate and by cutting out carbs and sugar
she really just meant like she wasn't
having big bowls of pasta because this
plan does contain carbs from fruit and
other whole grains and thank God because
like what would you eat without that so
yeah I took a little Peruzzi at this 22
Day meal plan and while the food
photography looks a little Martha
Stewart's Circa 2013. I feel like we
have something to work with here so
let's make breakfast okay so most of the
breakfast I see on this list here are
like fruit smoothies oatmeal or like
another cooked whole grain like quinoa
or a chia pudding now I did see a recipe
here for this like banana breakfast wrap
situation they don't give me any
information about what's in it but it's
seems like the most original recipe on
the list so we're gonna go with that
let's wrap it up
it up it's not a wrap recipe
without slammering her down okay whole
grain wrap I'm gonna like make this how
I make my kids bedtime snack because I
don't know when you say banana wrap this
is what I'm thinking about so we need
some glue edible glue just slap on some
pink blue yes a little 90s kid
conspiracy here what does PVA glue stand
for I'm gonna say Karen's very angry
yeah I like something like volatile
putrid volatile
aeration glue
what do you think guys
put your thoughts and theories
in the in the comments below because I
mean this is basically a huge huge
mystery of our times okay
banana these are like
strangely suspicious because they're
green but they're speckly so are they
ripe we'll never know a little honey
for some sweetness and it's kind of like
a little more sticky glue
PVA 2.0 uh banana
and I think we need to like two-thirds
it for the roll
all right now we tuck and roll rolling
with the homies Clueless
90s
reference all right that's a wrap but
also this is probably not enough for me
for breakfast so I'm gonna pair this up
with another of the breakfast options on
the list and make myself a little
smoothie okay so the recipe calls for
almond milk banana almond butter a scoop
of of course the Branded protein powder
and some leafy greens while I put this
all together Abby can you talk about the
importance of protein at breakfast you
got it girl so protein is an important
part of my Hunger crushing combo so of
course I think that we should try to get
it in most if not all meals protein is
key for supporting muscle mass energy
expenditure nighttime sleeps satiety
hormones glucose regulation and more and
in the context of weight loss
specifically a protein-rich breakfast
has been shown to help reduce calorie
intake later on in the day by
suppressing hunger hormones and reducing
signals in the brain responsible for the
food reward system also despite the
popularity of intermittent fasting which
does have some known benefits for weight
loss we actually know that front loading
our calories earlier on in the day is
more metabolically beneficial than
skipping breakfast and then eating later
on so personally I do try to eat a
really good solid meal in the morning it
really just sets the tone for the day
okay the combo is where it's at people I
could not personally go a whole morning
on just this or just this so we've got
protein in the protein powder lots of
healthy fats in the almond butter peanut
butter and the hemp hearts in there
carbs in our wrap and our banana
situation plus high fiber carbs in our
fruit veggies and wrap I don't even know
which to go in for first but cheers it's
a nice light mint green
so good A little wrap wrap
oh she's dripping look at that little
honey
Don't Escape
it looks so wrong
it looks wrong but it tastes right
all right breakfast in let's get a
little workout in and your girl is ready
for this jelly what the because jelly
all right so Beyonce's workout regimen
is something of Pop Culture myth and
lore given the goddess-like status that
she's achieved pretty much everyone
wants to know the secret to being
bootylicious myself included
but according to Rachel atard Beyonce
does 20 minutes of hit training then an
hour of strength training and then often
has dance rehearsals on top I think it's
safe to say that she ran this mother
[Music]
mother doesn't run
up get down for a little beehive Dance
Workout let's do it
[Music]
thank you
all right so far so good okay lunch
folks lunch lunch lunch let's see what
our options are so according to this
little listicle here usually it's like a
salad or soup sometimes there's like a
bit of carb in there sometimes not a
whole lot but I saw this like mango kale
avocado salad list a few times and I
feel like we can work with that don't
know really what's in it other than
those three things but
like we can work with that let's make a
salad
all right we got our kale
a little bit of kale here I'm gonna mix
it with
some leftover rice I just warmed up in
the microwave I like it kind of hot cold
salad situation making a mess I've got
some frozen edamame I just thought out
love that for us
we've got our mango oh and she's ripe
gonna waste any of that and some avocado
like that
this is looking good and fairly certain
the only carbs in the OG version is the
mango so I've added in the rice I've got
some cashews here for some healthy fats
and got a little sesame seeds
and because mayonnaise can make a better
salad dressing than I can a little sweet
Sesame vinaigrette all right I'm excited
about this we've got tons of fiber of
course from our Brown and wild rice and
our veggies and our edamame we got some
carbs in the mango and the rice as well
healthy fats in the Sesame and the
dressing and the cashews and the avocado
and of course some plant-based protein
in the edamame all right Abby while I
work my way through this can you tell us
a little bit about plant-based protein
and how it holds up to animal based
so it is true that plant-based proteins
generally have lower bioavailability
than animal-based proteins so about 40
years ago the idea of protein combining
was really in Vogue basically the idea
is that since most plant-based sources
of protein are low in one or more amino
acids that you have to combine two of
them in a meal to make that protein
complete the truth is our body maintains
a pool of free amino acids that it can
draw on to complement one another at any
time the protein we eat gets broken into
amino acids anyway so our body basically
can like mix and match amino acids to
get what we need so as long as the diet
is sufficient in calories and we're
eating a variety of plant-based proteins
it would be very hard to become actually
protein deficient for sure anyone who
says that you can't feel full and
satisfied on a plant-based diet has not
eaten a hunger crushing combo bowl like
this
so good I'm feeling like a little snack
even though you'll know I'm the whole
kitchen offered you a snack not the
whole kit
home kit so what do we have on the menu
Beyonce so according to this listicle we
have powerballs one of nutrition 22's
branded protein bars trail mix or
veggies with their hemp heart hummus
what how have I not thought of this so
let's make a little hemp heart dip and
while we do that Abby can you go over
why I'm so like crazy in love with the
stuff first of all let's set the record
straight here folks hemp products don't
get you high so no that is not the
reason that I'm drunk in love with this
stuff hey man do your thing I don't
understand it but do your thing but hem
parts are a built-in hunger crushing
combo that touts the benefit of
plant-based Omega-3s protein and fiber
of the super sprinkle Trifecta Chia flax
and hemp hemp is my personal go-to
because it's highest in zinc and protein
which are key nutrients especially with
plant-based diets and they have a really
mild nutty flavor that's super versatile
and delish okay I'm a little
disappointed because I was expecting it
to be like a real like hemp heart based
recipe but it's really just hummus with
some hemp hearts in it fine fine there's
nothing wrong with that I mean I
definitely could have thought that one
up myself little tahini a little lemon
juice all The Usual Suspects and a
hummus
a little garlic
and
the magic the hemp hurts
nice
this recipe didn't call for any oil but
I guess we've got enough fats coming
from the hemp and from the Tahiti and it
actually looks pretty good but it's
gonna need a [__] ton of salt so
a little salties I'm gonna grab some
paprika because yeah we're gonna need
flavor
you can take all that baby
a little taste Rooney
not bad it needs more lemon but it's not
bad and maybe a little more teeny
and you know what since we're here guys
because
you can't have oh that's not even olive
oil
I had to add some oil because I can't do
like the low fat hummus
I don't know why I haven't been putting
hem Parts into my hummus all along but
it's definitely an upgrade so we got
fiber in our beans veg and our crackers
for dipping we got tons of healthy fats
in the tahini and the hemp parts and the
Sesame here as well and we got protein
in the chickpeas and the Hem Parts as
well
it's really good approved queen bee
approved
all right folks let's talk dinner so I'm
not gonna lie I went through every
single day of this 22 Day meal plan and
there wasn't a single dinner that felt
inspiring so like here are some of our
options small baked sweet potato with
coconut oil half a cup of organic black
beans and steamed greens and no thank
you cup of quinoa with half an avocado
plus a cup of steamed greens and
vegetables what the [__] is that raw
zucchini Alfredo with basil cherry
tomatoes with steamed vegetables or
salad so just vegetables nice or
cauliflower rice with lemon mint and
pistachios over top of greens like
I'm gonna take a pass on that the best
selling option here was the butternut
squash curry with quinoa and steamed
vegetables so I'm gonna use that and
like reimagine it for my taste I'm going
to take a few creative Liberties let's
do it
let's pan fry a little tofu
a little neutral oil here avocado do a
little Bootylicious Dance while we wait
so impatient though
I feel like I'll get flagged if I put it
on all right let's get in there yeah we
don't need to be sued by the queen slash
King
salt Seas Pepsis
has Beyonce ever
in a Pepsi ad to all you beehive members
little Beyonce trivia is she team Coke
or Pepsi look it up look it up look it
up I don't know
all right that's looking good let's turn
this off for a second it's going to get
I knew this was good
I've lost a piece down in the great oh
she's hot she's hot she's hot she's hot
she's hot she's hot a little garlic and
ginger
[Music]
oh
a little paste got some red curry paste
stand back
[Music]
oh God
oh my God why is it so hot
okay okay folks gonna put the coconut
milk in now just to save myself from a
third degree burn that's what's the ER
right now
okay that's feeling
now we can catch our breath people all
right back to it I want butternut squash
because it is a [__] to cut and I don't
like it frozen so I've got sweet
potatoes here which is my opinion even
better
and I'm gonna add in some frozen kind of
stir-fry veg here
people poo poo frozen veg but honestly
in a lot of cases it's even better than
fresh because it is blanched and then
flash frozen to lock in those nutrients
so I'm a huge fan of Frozen fruits and
vegetables especially when the prices
right now are out of control
[Music]
all right tofu in all right
it smells so good folks
so so good you guys know I don't do
quinoa because to me it tastes kind of
like mush so I plated mine up with some
white rice which I much prefer and don't
hate on white rice folks we have so many
Hunger crushing compounds here we've got
protein in our tofu we got healthy fats
in our nuts and our coconut milk and our
Sesame and a lot of fiber in all of that
veg so we've dressed up those naked
carbs really damn good so I'm really not
worried about any kind of blood sugar
Spike from the white rice okay are you
guys team fork or spoon when it comes to
rice and Curry because I am all about
the spoon so you can get all the little
sassy bits off the bottom of the bowl
look at that
it's so good and the sweet potato smells
better than butternut squash in my
opinion just saying
all right my favorite time of day folks
it's dessert and surprisingly for a no
carb diet there's actually a lot of
options here so most of the desserts I
see on this plan were either just like
dark chocolate I don't know how much
you're allowed to have a raw vegan
brownie bite raw chocolate pudding or
raw vegan macarons I actually loved kind
of like that chocolate raw avocado
pudding my kids love it too so I'm gonna
work with that and while I do that Abby
what's the whole dealio on this whole
raw vegan Trend listen I am all for
plant-based diets or at least trying to
incorporate more plant-based Foods into
your day I'm also for no bake desserts
because honestly who has the time or
patience to bake in the middle of a work
week not me but there are some major
concerns with eating an exclusively raw
plant-based diet namely that you're
basically limited to fruits veggies nuts
and seeds since pretty much all of the
plant-based sources of protein like
beans legumes and whole grains need to
be cooked so we're looking at Major
nutrient deficiencies in B12 zinc
protein and potentially calories and for
women specifically this can result in
major reproductive Health declines with
one study suggesting that 30 percent of
raw dieters lost their period so yeah
eat your raw dessert but don't go fully
raw
avocado
step one and it doesn't even matter if
it's cheap folks because it's going into
the blender and it's gonna get covered
in chocolate so this is a great way to
use up those
non-guacamole worthy avos squeezer in
a couple tablespoons of cocoa powder
um
what should they have to come up with a
better system I mean definitely I should
have completely removed the packaging
but moving on
sugar
I probably needed a larger
oh
I have this recipe and you know when you
do that and then you inevitably [__]
something up it almost happened but I'm
still on track
I'm gonna we're gonna get through this
day without a [__] up brown sugar down
coconut milk let's do that now you will
watch as I successfully open a can with
a can opener that no one else in this
world knows how to work no one else on
my team knows how to work this in the
job description and yet no one can
figure it out okay how much more I'm
gonna say like
a little bit more than that oh yeah
she's gonna be creamy a little vanilla
beep all right let's blend her up
actually not
I know what this means
salt
if you know you know and if you don't
I'll tell you that salt is really
important for helping to kind of tone
down some of the bitterness of cocoa
powder it's key it's key in everything
but particularly when it comes to kind
of more bitter flavors I think
hours later
okay so like definitely not conducive to
a rock star performance all right I'm
gonna finish mine off with a little
Fleur de cell to keep it super fancy I
mean we gotta make it appropriate for
the queen and let's get in there look
how thick this is
so good packed with healthy fats and
fiber and honestly I wouldn't care if it
wasn't because chocolate
um oh my God it is so good it is so good
especially with that little hit of salt
on top
so let's recap we did have to take a few
creative liberties with Beyonce's tour
prep regimen but I actually think we
ended up with a pretty balanced
nutritious plant-based day and I'm all
about the plant-based inspiration I also
appreciate that besides the plant-based
piece this is probably not how Beyonce
eats on a regular basis according to a
lot of the reports I read usually
Beyonce eats several small meals
throughout the day to keep her energy
levels high with a balance of healthy
fats protein and carbs which you guys
know we love to see she also recently
opened up to Harper's Bazaar about her
experiences with insomnia yo-yo dieting
and the impact the excessive touring has
had on our body mentioning that the
strict dieting and exercise regimen left
her with a lot of muscle pain aches and
stressed out hair and skin so let this
be a reminder that what celebrities put
themselves for a singular moment in time
is ultimately not sustainable and it
also generally leaves these folks
feeling really dry greened and not so
great so hopefully Beyonce's being able
to collect that doubt of herself and
learn for next time that maybe she
doesn't need such a long no no no list
and guys I hope you enjoyed this video
if you did be sure to give it the thumbs
up leave me a comment below on Whose
diet you'd like to see me attempt next
subscribe to the channel and I'll see
you next time on Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]